Woody Harrelson about six months ago was
on it was right before I was on he was
on Bill Maher's podcast the club random
podcast and he was talking while stoned
about all of the government and Pharma
collusion related to blocking cheap
drugs here's the CDC promoting that we
have to do all of these things right I
just I don't like profiteering in war
you know think of the billions of
dollars that have gone to Big Pharma but
I was getting back to my original point
the last people I would trust with my
health
his big Pharma and big government
because neither one of those strike me
as caring entities spoken as the perfect
redneck hippie really if that message
doesn't mean they're all about profit
exactly you're all about profit and both
sides I've seen the profit they've made
I think they've done a lot of studies
about vitamin D and how important it was
when the people who had low levels they
were much more
um
vulnerable to covid why not tell people
that can't you make money selling
vitamin D is it that kind of what's the
worst that could happen that's just it
man there was only one thing you know
Ivermectin got made into a you know
horse tranquilizer uh a horse whatever
it is which it is but also used by
humans it would use my millions and
millions of years uh
hydroxychloroquine got uh made
ridiculous
um and there was only one thing that
could work and that's the vaccine right
and so ultimately because of that
billions of dollars was made
so it's interesting the reason I'm
showing you this is not to tell you that
Woody Harrelson is the biggest genius in
the world but isn't he laying out a lot
more truth than what you would get from
someone at CNN or the New York Times etc
etc he's asking the right questions and
he's he's making it personal I don't
believe that big government or big
Pharma has my own health in their
interests they sort of want us to be
weak and unable to do anything or think
straight about things and our immune
systems compromise so that we can always
be on their drugs Bill is doing a little
bit of kind of defending the system
can't they make money off Vitamin D well
the thing is you could just walk outside
and get a little sunshine and you'll get
your vitamin D
foreign
[Music]